in 1845 a Scottish physician named John
Bennett carried out an autopsy on a
28-year old man who had died suddenly he
noticed that the man's spleen and liver
were greatly enlarged while his veins
were clogged with white infection
fighting cells in previous cases like
this doctors had taken this pus like
substance as a sign of infection
but Bennett diagnosed a disorder of the
blood itself a malfunction from within
the body rather than an attack from
without just five weeks later a doctor
in Germany named Rudolf Virchow
published a similar case report via Chow
described an imbalance in his patients
blood healthy blood is composed of
mostly red blood cells and plasma with
just one percent white blood cells but
the majority of this patients blood was
white Virchow called the disease
leukemia from the Greek word Lucas or
white and heimer or blood about 350,000
people worldwide are diagnosed with
leukemia or cancer of the blood each
year cancer occurs when genetic
mutations cause abnormal cells to divide
and multiply in an uncontrolled way but
unlike most cancers leukemic cells don't
belong to an organ like the lungs or
stomach and don't result in the growth
of a tumor instead the uncontrolled cell
growth takes place in the bone marrow
the marrow is the body's blood factory
where a single type of multipotent stem
cell divides and matures to give rise to
12 different kinds of blood cell
leukemia can occur at different stages
of this process and in virtually every
type of blood cell in all cases the
abnormal cells build up and fill the
bone marrow ultimately preventing other
cells from developing the cancerous
cells can also spread to other organs in
the body the rate at which leukemia
progresses and the course of treatment
differ depending on the type of cells
affected
when a normal stem cell divides it
produces one of two slightly more
specific cells called myeloid and
lymphoid stem cells these give rise to
several other cell types each myeloid
cell eventually becomes a red blood cell
a platelet or an infection fighting
macrophage when cancer occurs in these
cells it's known as myeloid leukemia
lymphoid cells develop into T B and
natural killer cells cancer occurring in
these cells is called lymphoid leukemia
when cancerous mutations show up in a
myeloid or lymphoid cell that is still
developing abnormal cells quickly fill
the marrow and interfere with normal
function this form of the disease is
known as acute leukemia because it
progresses so rapidly as cancerous cells
proliferate the rate of normal blood
cell production plungers chronic forms
of leukemia occur in more mature
lymphoid or myeloid cells the irregular
cells build up in the bone marrow over a
period of years interrupting the
production of normal blood cells and
spreading to other parts of the body
these categories acute and chronic
lymphoid and myeloid are used to assign
cases of leukemia to one of four
subtypes acute lymphoid leukemia chronic
lymphoid leukemia acute myeloid leukemia
and chronic myeloid leukemia acute
lymphoid leukemia or al L primarily
occurs in young children between the
ages of one and for the other three
types most often strike later in life
particularly after the age of 70 when
rudolf virchow gave leukemia its name no
successful therapies existed and the
disease was nearly always fatal but
prognosis has vastly improved since then
thanks to the development of
chemotherapy and other treatments such
as bone marrow transplants within the
past few decades a person's chance of
surviving for five years after diagnosis
has risen by an average of about 20
percent for people with chronic myeloid
leukemia CML survival rates have climbed
even more by about 30 percent thanks to
the development of the first targeted
cancer therapy now researchers are
working to understand the genetic
underpinnings of other forms of leukemia
and to decipher the molecular secrets of
leukemic stem cells lessons learned from
these and other research efforts hold
promise for the development of new more
effective weapons for combating leukemia
and may also provide key insights in the
broader war against cancer in all its
forms
you